CENTER ICE TO OKPOSO.
OKPOSO GETTING IN OVER THE LINE.
SABRES TAKE IT BACKWINNIPEG TRYE
IN ON GOAL.
.
OUT IN FRONT BACK TO THE POINT
GIRGENSONS.
ZEMGUS GIRGENSONS WAS THERE AND
HE HAMMERED IT HOME. OVER 'EM
HERE CREATING CHANCES.
GIRGENSONS GETS ONE CHANCE, THE.
BROUGHT TO THE FOR THE REMAINDE
OF THE PERIOD AND START OF THE
SECOND.
KEPT IN BYPASS IT COMES TO CENT.
IN OVER THETHE NET.
DUBOIS, BACKHAND, HE SCORES. IN.
>> Rick: HE WAS IN THE NET.
>> Rob: GOING AGAIN.
MITTELSTADT, WITH THE PUCK.
OVERUPPORT.
GIRGENSONS INITIALLY TAKES IT
IN.
THE SUPPORT BY OKPOSO, WORKS IT.
PASS IN FRONT OFF IT IN
THERE BUT THE J J ACROSS ICE.
THEY APPLETON IN BEHIND
DYLAN COZENS ABACK TO THE POINT.
IN
JOKIHARJU.
AND GREAT PART ABOUT IT, NEVER
SANFORD THROUGH CENTER.
IN OVER THE LINE ALL THEHE TO C.
HINOSTROZA GETS INTO A SHOOTING
LANE, TAKES A SHOT RIGHT OUT OF
SIX OF THE LAST SEVEN.
AND RACING AFTER IT IS THOMPSON
TRYING TO GET AWAY.SLASHING.
>> Rob: TAKE AGHT ON.
KICKED AWAY.
THE REBOUND RIGHT IN FRONT OF
THE THE ICE BY
BUFFALO.
ANDDEIFELE WILL BE
THE NEXT ONE FOR THE JETS.TAKE .
SCORES.
WHEELER TAPPED IT IN AND